- [Mark] All right, Annie.
Annie, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- Louisiana
What part of Louisiana?
- Shreveport.
- [Mark] Shreveport.
And tell me about your family.
You grew up with both of your parents?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Tell me about your family.
You grew up with both of your parents?
- I grew up with my grandparents
because my mother and father passed away
when I was young.
I lost my dad when I was nine.
I lost my mom when I was 13.
So my father's mom, my
grandmother raised us.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- Huh?
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- My father, how was he?
- I don't.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- How old?
- My father was okay, but he
was like, he was never home.
He was always,
you know, out there
with the others, you know,
selling heroin,
stuff like that, you know.
My grandmother didn't like
it because my mother was
on it and he always had
supplies for her, you know.
She didn't have to worry
about going to get it.
- [Mark] Right.
- I guess, by him giving it
to her, he got hooked up.
So, you know, she hated
her ever since then.
- [Mark] So your parents were addicts?
- Yeah, 'cause my father,
she said he, she turned him into one.
- [Mark] And then you,
you left home at what age?
- 16.
- [Mark] 6, ¿and where'd you go?
- I was living in, I was in
the Valley, San Fernando Valley
with my grandparents and I just
got tired of getting yelled
at and beaten, you know, for any little,
dumb shit, ya know.
Anything was stupid.
I don't know.
My grandmother was a mean person, okay?
She was very wicked.
I just got tired.
I called the police.
I ran away.
Oh, the police, I don't know.
Eventually they put me in a foster home
because they got tired of the bullshit.
My auntie, she said we
don't want her no more.
Just take her away.
So they put me in a foster home, you know,
and I stayed there 'til
I was about 16, 17.
Like, you know, I got out there on my own.
- [Mark] And then when
you're out there on your own,
how was, how did your life go?
I mean, did you?
- I guess okay, because I'm still here.
- [Mark] You are.
- You know what I'm saying?
I've grown on street
on my own to survive.
It's called surviving.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Doing what I gotta do to live.
- [Mark] Did you ever get married?
- And I'm 58 years old
and I made it this far.
- [Mark] Did you ever
get married or have kids?
- No, no.
It's like I had a whole
map, but it was like
it wasn't a good relationship.
You know, when he didn't
have his way or didn't like.
I didn't like getting hit.
'Cause I got tired when I get hit,
you know, I said, oh no, I don't.
It's going right back at me.
I'm leaving it from her.
I'm trying to get away from
my grandparents doing it now.
Now he's, you know,
I just got like, got me
all confused in the brain.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- That's why they put me
under a doctor, like a psych
because I was shaking.
I have mental problems.
I used to have night, wake
up crying out of my sleep
because things, I have flashbacks
of what my grandparents did
or something happened to me
with my old man did to me.
I had bad.
I've just had bad dreams.-
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You know?
It's just like, I don't know.
It just had me like out of it.
So they gave me some, some nerves,
some pills to calm my nerves
and to help me sleep and
relax because I used,
I'm a lot better now.
But before, if you see me before
than now, you wouldn't believe it.
I was like a nervous wreck,
everything, anybody, you know,
just calm down.
We're not going to do nothing to.
I couldn't, I was just,
it had me like that.
It took me a long time
to come up out of it.
The doctor said.
- [Mark] Do you think that was because
of the things that happened in the past?
- Happened to me in the past, yeah.
Being yelled at and being hit.
'Cause every time you raise your hand
I don't know how I'm gonna
get hit again or what
you know what I'm saying?
It just,
it just had me all shook up.
The doctor said that's a natural cause.
That's from that, that
can happen to anyone.
- [Mark] Sure.
- Especially from a child, I was a child
especially from a child up to adult
because my old man used to do it.
Not this one.
My first one used to do it.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh, no, everywhere, I'm going
I'm just getting bopped,
bopped around, you know,
for no reason.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And a person get, well, I know I do.
I get tired of it.
Why should I get hit for
something I don't do?
If anything, I'm out there surviving.
Trying to help both of us.
You know, this is when I
was living in Hollywood
before I came here.
You know, everything I did was
for both of us, you know.
I never cheated on him.
I never went behind his back.
I don't know.
I think he likes the icky ones, okay?
He likes the ones that he could just slap
around back, you know?
But I'm not going to, I wasn't going
for that because I
didn't do it to get that.
But he was doing it.
Every time somebody look,
he'd start eyeballing them, when they look
you know, how somebody just
walk by and looking at you.
Oh, now y'all.
I contacted.
I said, what do you mean?
I don't even know what you talking about.
I see him looking at you.
And I said, I said, no, you're wrong.
This man would be.
I mean, he's looking at me.
That don't mean I'm
looking at him, you know?
You're the one who's
seeing all that, I'm not.
You know, it was, I dunno.
I just used to get so shook.
I didn't know what to do.
Sometimes, I just run from
him because I'd be so scared.
- [Mark] How long have you
been down here on Skid Row?
- Huh?
- [Mark] How long have
you been here on Skid Row?
- Down here?
- [Mark] Yes.
- I've been here five years now.
At my place.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- So that's how long?
Five years.
- [Mark] Before, you were at
the hotel around the corner?
- Excuse me.
No, no hotels, apartment.
It's a single bachelor apartment.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- 'Cause before that it was
like motel to motel.
That costs a lot of money.
I've been here five years.
- [Mark] And are, do
you use any of the drugs
that are on the street?
- I did, in Hollywood years ago and stuff,
you know, but now now, no.
- [Mark] You're clean now.
- I just get nervous now.
I'm just having a nervous condition.
Everything's scares me.
You know, I'm just tired.
I don't know, I get tired.
I'm getting old.
I'm 58 years old, I guess
everything's getting.
I'm just getting tired of everything.
Seems like my body just wants to shut down
but I don't want myself to shut down.
You know, I'm trying to
keep myself motivated
keep going, keep going, keep going.
So I have to do what I gotta
do to keep going, you know?
Oh yeah.
People offered me a joint.
People offer me a drink.
I don't do none of that.
People bring, whatever else, you know,
I just tell them no.
I've done, I did that and done that.
I don't want it no more because
I might get the wrong car.
You might give me something wrong
and then it might kill me.
- [Mark] Right.
- I don't know what I'm messing with.
And this is like 58 years ago.
'Cause I'm 58.
You know what I'm saying?
It's been a long time for me.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I'm still out here doing
what I'm doing on the street
but I'm doing that for me to survive.
- [Mark] What do you do for money?
- I get like a hundred
something every month
but that food goes so fast.
You know, basically it's
for my food, buy cigarettes.
'Cause I smoke cigarettes,
you know, stuff like that.
And I ain't got nothing.
The money I make has
nothing to do with drugs.
Everything is just something for me.
If I need money to wash
clothes or whatever
do my laundry, you know, what I'm saying?
Or if I need a new pair of
under or whatever, you know.
- [Mark] what do you do to make?
- But then I don't get
all that money that I
should get maybe 20 here, 40
that ain't going to get all what I want.
You follow me?
You follow what I'm saying.
So I have to go out every
day to get what I need
'til I get it all where I want.
Until I get all what I want.
You know, it might take a while,
but I'm getting it, eventually.
- [Mark] And what, what do
you do to make extra money?
- Huh?
- [Mark] what do you
do to make extra money?
- Extra money?
Whatever.
They're like golden showers
or just a straight day or
find them another girl.
Oh, excuse me.
- [Mark] So, so you'll
date guys sometimes.
- Huh?
- [Mark] You will date guys sometimes?
You will go out with guys sometimes?
- That's what I be doing
now, I date guys, yeah.
That's how I make my money.
- [Mark] That's what I'm asking.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I just wanted to make sure.
- Excuse me.
That's what I be doing now.
Yeah, I have some regulars.
You know, some of them really like me.
They come back and we
just hang out or whatever.
They take me out to eat.
You know, it's just not
all about having sex,
it's about the.
It's all about to know, to know a person.
Get to know a person.
Because you never know when
you might need that help.
We all need somebody in our corner.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You know, we all do.
And that's what, that's
how I look at it, you know.
Hey, if I got the rubber
or if they got the
rubber, hey, we'll date.
But if you ain't got no
rubber, sorry, Charlie
ain't no dating happening
because you're not going to catch me.
You ain't going to get me no AIDS,
or Gono, whatever that is.
You know what I'm saying?
Because I don't know
who that person has been
with before that person got with me.
You follow me?
- [Mark] Understood.
I don't know if he,
when he ever comes home
I don't want to give it to him.
'Cause he ain't doing nothing in jail
unless he busting back
the back or whatever.
El Lado Oscuro por Mark Laita
Let me hush, that's enough.
I don't want to talk
more about that stuff.
- [Mark] Thank you so much
for talking to me, Annie.
- Okay, no problem.
Can I go now or do I have
to keep wasting my breath?
- [Mark] We're all done, we're all done.
Okay, baby.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- I appreciate it.
Is there anything?
Can I have, do you have a
little cup or something?
I guess a water.
- [Mark] I'm gonna get you a water.
- Yeah, because I'm
talking, my mouth gets dry.